[Music]
hey you guys time once again for tomes
of terror my book review show and again
i'm doing some more stuff that was
available to read for free on kindle
unlimited
now interestingly i just picked a bunch
of books that were recommended again
that were available for kindle unlimited
that the first sentence of the synopsis
sounded like really cool and really
interesting to me
and i checked out a bunch of them
because i don't know if you have kindle
unlimited i don't know if you know but
you can have like 10 books checked out
at the same time
so i will usually check out all the
books that i'm going to read for that
month
just you know so i can get ahead if i
need to and whatnot so i had put this in
the queue like probably several weeks
back before february even started now
the weird thing about it though is that
this is totally unintentional and i
don't really know how this happens like
the little coincidences like this happen
all the time but this book right here
uh which is called only the stains
remain by ross jeffrey
not only was the author of this a
british author from bristol just like
the author gemma amore uh on the book
six rooms which i reviewed on my last
tombs of terror show
but this was also published by
cemetery gates media i believe it's
called which is like an independent
publishing house which i believe was
also the same publishing house that
published six rooms by gemma moore so uh
i thought that was pretty weird and like
i said i didn't uh do that on purpose i
guess they just kind of came up in a
batch like all together
this book actually it's rat it's really
not like a novel it's a novella uh it's
only about 120 125 pages somewhere
around there but this one came out a bit
earlier than six rooms did i believe
this came out back in summer of
2021 like back in july because i
remember seeing um i went back and
looked and there were actually several
uh youtubers uh booktubers that had done
uh reviews of this
right about like right before it came
out because they got uh arcs from the uh
publisher so a lot of them had covered
it and uh pretty much to a man like all
of them were very very positive uh
reviews and i'm going to give this a
positive review too although there was a
couple things about it that i wasn't
crazy about
but i'll get into that now there is
actually a content warning at the
beginning of this book and i'm gonna
give you one as well
if you
uh do not want to read about and fairly
graphically described
uh physical and sexual abuse of children
and the aftermath of that then probably
you might want to avoid this book
because it goes
there and it goes like some pretty dark
places the stuff that is described is
not it's not super graphically described
but it's
described enough that you can
imagine it you know that you can picture
it in the back your mind and it's pretty
disturbing so if you really don't want
to read anything kind of soul-crushing
like that i'm putting this in the same
category as
you know something maybe like jack
ketchum's girl next door or something
like that where
it's just kind of about
the worst people imaginable doing
horrible horrible things to completely
innocent people and it will just you
know make you hate humanity
so if you don't really want to feel it's
not a fun read i'll say that right now
so if you don't want to read anything
like that
then maybe avoid it uh but otherwise you
know it's i for whatever reason i
read these kind of books all the time i
don't know if enjoying them is the word
that i'm looking for but
i don't know i do enjoy them to an
extent but maybe that's like a weird
thing to say
so uh essentially what we have here is
it's kind of like
it goes back and forth it's you know
it's the the protagonist the book it's
from his point of view and his name is
jude
and he's talking from the present day
and he's talking about
what happened to him and his brother
kyle uh back in 1982 when they were
little kids
now i will say that this novella has
pretty much one of the best like opening
lines of like pretty much any horror
novel i've ever read i mean it's one of
those opening lines where you just read
it and you're like okay i'm invested now
which which is very very very difficult
to do and plus it has a quote uh from
stephen king's uh i believe it's the
wasteland in there so you know that's
kind of the vibe that it's uh going for
so
jude who is now an adult uh is kind of
it's it's essentially set up where
he's talking from the present day and
he's basically just the book's in like
three or four different sections
and
he goes
back like something he has like a bag
full of objects
and he will take one out and it will
remind him of the stuff that happened
back in 1982
and then we'll go back and you know get
into that and like what ended up
happening
so what happened to them when they were
kids like he was younger his brother
kyle was older and they had like a very
very close relationship kyle was very
protective
of jude
now when they were quite young
their mother who they both loved very
much
died of cancer
now after their mother dies their father
who previously seemed like he had been
like an okay dude
uh he just kind of like checked out
uh started drinking a great deal became
overtly abusive he just like didn't care
about anything anymore um you know just
because he couldn't deal with
seeing the kids it kept reminding him of
his dead wife and you know he so he just
wasn't like having it anymore
probably even worse than that because
you know i'm not going to say like the
worst thing that the dad did was neglect
because he did some worse [ __ ] too
but uh so he was basically just neglect
neglectful and was also like physically
abusive like he would smack the kids
around he treated them like slave labor
[ __ ] like that
just because he couldn't deal with his
wife's death and he just got drunker and
drunker you know as the time went on
however
what was even worse than that
was that after uh the mother died
two of the dad's brothers the two of the
kids uncles plus this other guy who's
called an uncle but was actually just
like a family friend uh they're called
lenny lucius and dwight
and they
now see i saw some other reviews that
said they moved into the house i didn't
get the implication that they moved into
the house i just got the implication
that they were just like around all the
time like that maybe they lived nearby
and they would come by there
so
what these uh i mean i'm sure you can
probably imagine like where this is
going you know considering what i said
earlier
but these three scumbags
uh basically take it upon themselves to
start
uh physically emotionally mentally and
sexually abusing
first the older boy kyle
now kyle is kind of like as i said
earlier he's very very protective of his
younger brother jude so he essentially
kind of
he tries to like take all of the pain
onto himself
to
keep the guys you know keep the uncles
from hurting his younger brother so for
a long time he's being sexually abused
um but he's keeping the he's keeping the
uncles from doing it to the younger boy
but you know that
eventually
that's not gonna last
and indeed it does not
but for a long time he does kind of take
it upon himself to
try and keep
i guess like these
these dirt bags like attention away from
uh the younger kid now the the uncles do
other things too like they take them out
on these hunting trips they all get
super drunk one of them makes jude
they catch like a baby boar
and tie it up by its feet and like make
a jude kill it and it's like they do all
kind of [ __ ] up stuff like that and
again eventually uh it gets to a point
where at first it starts out with the
younger boy jude um
that one of the uncles i think it's
dwight actually um start like burns him
with cigarettes like he's claiming him
uh you know so there's that and then
eventually uh it goes into sexual abuse
as well
so
you're kind of given this story in
flashback uh as you're going on but it's
structured in the sense that in the
present day as i said jude is
essentially um
going on this sort of journey of
vengeance against the men that
perpetrated uh this atrocity
so each section of the book
is basically him getting revenge on one
of the guys you know what i mean it's
strange because as i said it's a novella
so it's fairly short
it's not so much
it's kind of weird it's kind of like odd
because you would think i once i kind of
got into the swing of it i was kind of
like oh well we're gonna like follow him
as he you know tracks down each guy and
like what he does to him and stuff which
it's kind of like that
but usually what happens at the
beginning of the section where he's
dealing with you know uncle lenny or
whatever he's they don't really um the
author doesn't really show
him
capturing the guy it's almost kind of
like he's already in custody like he's
already got him like tied up
and then he'll say like you know this is
how i got him like the one guy he like
you know i saw him i knew where he was
because i'd been like watching him for a
while and then i just ran him over with
the car so it like broke his leg so he
can go anywhere and then like he tied
him up and then you know he does
different things to each of them
but it doesn't go too much into
the process of it i guess is that like a
weird thing to say he does it doesn't go
much into the process it's kind of like
it seems like that is kind of like the
short shrift
and
when i was first thinking about it i
said i said this seems like a very
strange choice to like go so much into
what the kids suffered i guess it's not
that strange a choice well like what the
kids suffered back in 1982 but then when
it gets to what is presumably the you
know the catalyst or the um you know the
cathartic
uh revenge against the perpetrators it's
almost like not
as prolonged you know what i mean like
he does kind of
you know like one of the guys he does
like tie him up by his you know feet and
like hang him from a tree and he leaves
them there for a bit so they can like
think about what they did and everything
like that but then after that like you
know his him killing him is like
pretty quick
so i kind of thought and
well like i i was weirded out by that at
first but then i thought well maybe he's
kind of making the point that
he doesn't want to become even though he
does say at points in the book that like
you know to
defeat a monster you have to become a
monster
but i think that they wanted to i think
he wanted to like pull some punches on
that a little bit where he's like well
yeah like
the stuff that jude is doing to these
men is completely and utterly justified
i mean considering what the [ __ ] they
did to him and his brother when they
were children
but it's almost like he wants to show
that but he doesn't want to like linger
on it too much which i wasn't sure if i
was down with that decision at first but
like the more i think about it because i
finished reading it yesterday
but the more i think about it i think
well maybe that was actually like a good
decision
because this book i feel like and i saw
like a couple of other youtubers that
maybe like gave me a little bit of
perspective on this that a lot of
youtubers were like one woman in
particular said you know she had
suffered um pretty bad like neglect and
abuse when she was a child as well
and her way of dealing with it
was to write stories
about how she was going to horribly
torture and kill the people that did it
to her
which like i said understandable
so for her this book was very very
cathartic because she said this is
exactly the kind of face it's not like
you're gonna do it it's just that that's
your way of dealing with
uh you know your trauma
and it's a perfectly valid way of going
about it like reading something like
this and you know it's it's sort of like
you know like a fantasy
release you know you're you're kind of
like imagining how you're gonna get back
at these
men who you know who you should have
been able to trust because they were in
you know they were entrusted to take
care of you that's your dad that's your
uncle's and they just uh completely
to put it like
completely just completely dropped the
ball on that uh and just like brutalize
them instead and the reverberations of
that like for the kids
how you know [ __ ] horrible that would
be and how you would just like never be
able to have a normal life afterward so
so the plot of this book it's not
i i'm not really all that worried about
like spoiler alert or anything like that
because the book is almost not even i
don't want to say it's not structured
like uh like a regular narrative but in
the sense that because it does have you
know one thing happen when the one thing
happened but it's almost kind of like
episodic and i think i said that about
six rooms as well
these books they're completely different
but they do have some kind of like
similarities which i think is sort of
interesting and i don't know if it's
because the same publisher because the
authors are from the same place or i
don't know what it was but they're as i
said they're completely completely
different uh stories and tones but there
are some similarities between them that
i thought was interesting in the sense
that this one is also kind of episodic
in the sense that
you know in the future like in the
present rather jude is kind of like hey
i have this belt buckle in the bag and
then i'm gonna tell you about what this
uncle did to me and my brother back in
1982 and what i just did to him
and then it just you know it it just
keeps going like that so it's a so there
aren't like any plot twists or surprises
or anything like that it's basically
just a straight up revenge story it's
pretty much like
matter of fact it's kind of like i spit
on your grave you know what i mean if
you've seen that
that movie from the 70s where you know a
woman is gang raped by four or five guys
and then she just you know uh
methodically like goes and
tortures and kills each one of them the
end so this is structured very much like
that so like i said there's not going to
be like any plot twist or anything like
that so don't worry about it getting
spoiled for you or anything like that
but
it's just kind of
just a straight revenge story and i
quite enjoyed it i think that there was
as i said i think it took a bit for me
to kind of get into it because
i because it was such uh you know such
an episodic sort of read rather than
like a long like narrative arc rather so
but once i kind of got into the swing of
that i you know got more into it the
writing is actually quite evocative like
quite beautiful
a lot of it is
descriptive i will say that um there's
bits that are like a little bit
repetitive in the sense that i mean
because he's just you know
picking off these four men one by one
and
each time he's kind of like saying he's
you know he's going to his mother's and
his brother's graves and he's saying you
know i'm going to get them back for you
i'm going to kill them that's the
promise i made when i was a kid so
it does kind of like repeat that
uh in a way so
uh so it is kind of like that so
know that going into it i will say and
this is something too that i brought up
when uh when i was talking about six
rooms was that there were some typos i
will say that not anything egregious but
one thing that was a lot of this and i
guess i'm not sure if it was just um
ross jeffrey's writing style a lot of
run-on sentences uh
meaning that using a comma when you
should be using a period or a semicolon
uh so there was that and maybe that's
just like his writing style and that's
cool because you don't have to be
completely grammatically correct
but it did i don't know i'm so like i
said i'm kind of like i'm kind of like a
grammar nazis and stuff like that like
sort of bothers me because i'm like that
really should be a period there or a
semicolon like at the very least but you
know what i mean i don't know so uh you
know i i didn't mean to be like i don't
i don't mean to be like super pedantic
about it but you guys know how i am but
yeah so
this book uh as i said
it's pretty soul-crushing it's pretty as
i said it's not graphic in the sense
that but but
it doesn't really shy away from the [ __ ]
either you know what i'm saying so if
you don't really want to read anything
about two little boys
being sexually abused being physically
abused uh you know and then somebody
getting horrible revenge on the people
that did it it's actually kind of a
beautiful story in a way
but
it's also pretty crushing it's also
pretty
depressing
um just because
the antagonists are just these horrible
scumbag like with no redeeming qualities
whatsoever
and you know that there are really
people like that in the world and it's
just kind of like bums you out so you
know what i mean in in much the same way
that jack ketchum is the girl next door
you really have to be like in the right
headspace to read that because otherwise
it's just going to make you want to kill
yourself um this is this one's not quite
that bad but it's the same it's along
the same kind of lines so it's not a fun
read it's not something you take to the
beach or nothing like that like in the
summer time oh it's breezy yeah it's
really not but yeah it's overall i
really did enjoy this there were a
couple issues that i had with it being
like a little repetitious or
whatever and like i said the run on
sentence thing kind of bothered me
because you know how i do uh but other
than that this was actually quite a
powerful story uh very evocative the
descriptions and everything like that uh
and ultimately
quite um quite a beautiful story even
though it's about
you know horrible revenge
but again very cathartic particularly
for people who are
survivors of abuse of this type
i imagine they would probably find
something like this
quite cathartic so
if you've read this particular book only
the stains remain uh let me know let me
know what you thought of it if you did
uh if not as i said if you have kindle
unlimited you can read it for free on
there it's quite short like i said it's
only about 120 pages it's a novella uh
so if it sounds like something that you
would like then read it and get back to
me in the comments what you thought
about it and that will do it for this
tomes of terror i will see you guys on
the next one
bye